well if you're a regular viewer of this
show you've noticed there's been
something missing for the past couple of
months
probably our favorite guest columnist
mark stein has not been on this program
we're practically to send
liam neeson out to track him down and
return him
but mark stein is back with us tonight
and we're grateful for it welcome back
mark
hey great to great to be back with you
tucker yeah liam neeson
rescued me from uh a bunch of albanians
who'd been uh who'd been holding me it's
it's taken 12 coming to
the multiplex near you anytime soon
i'll be i'll be first in line what do
you make of this
i i the democratic socialists of america
seem like
they've been taken over by a bunch of
trusteefarians from brooklyn
is that do you think what's happened
yeah i think it's actually sometimes you
see
mass movements that actually dwindle
into
niche markets it happens a lot
broadway for example used to be the
mainstream of american popular culture
and then became a little boutique thing
same thing happened with jazz
and these guys have gone the same way
and in fact they're using the same
choreography
those jazz hands uh i don't understand
why
clapping you've been talking about real
problems with men in america
we're now watching a political
convention where clapping is so
triggering uh everybody in says had to
make jazz hands like
a lot of camp assistant choreographers
uh rehearsing some number from hello
dolly
i don't like that i find jazz hands
triggering because it reminds me of
old-time mammy singers
so it's like being at a convention of
the virginia
democrat governor and lieutenant
governor and all the rest of them
all doing all doing their mammy songs uh
this
this is the degeneration socialism
slaughtered millions these trustifarians
couldn't slaughter anybody
they're not serious socialists
we've really missed you and yet as
angela nagle said
and i think it's a fair point and that's
why this is worth taking a look at
they do have an effect on the mainstream
of the democratic party i mean
they're using language that
unfortunately elizabeth warren uses or
beto o'rourke or that booker kid from
new jersey is running for president i
mean
they they seem to be cribbing their
notes
from the dsa yeah i think that's what
angela got wrong i mean no one's
interested in uh
you know the controlling heights of the
economy this nonsense is actually what
they're about
and if you listen to the democrat debate
which i watched from thousands of miles
away so it seemed even weirder
cory booker at one point said we don't
talk enough about trans americans
and in particular we don't talk enough
about african-american
trans i want to make sure i get this
right african-american trans americans
and of course the answer to that is that
on these terms you can never talk enough
about african-american trans-americans
uh this uh this uh obsession with
boutique demographics which they take as
seriously
it's basically like downton abbey for
progressives
it's does the second son of the vi count
uh
get to sit next to the younger daughter
of the marquis
that is actually this this oh well i am
a white woman of privilege
so i have to sit down at the far end of
the table because an
african-american trans-american
non-binary person
gets to sit at the head of the table
they take it all seriously the
presidential candidates take it
seriously
it's an al alternative reality that
they've successfully created
and it's boring as hell if only they
would spend four minutes telling us what
they think of the federal reserve bank
i'd be kind of excited
mark spine they've never heard of the
federal reserve
great to be back with you jacka what
does that have to do with trans
americans
thank you good to see you